Speaker 1: MSNBC interviewed Pittsburgh area
Trump voters in the lead up to the imminent
election about January 6th. And I'm going to play
some of this for you. And what you are going to
see demonstrated in this clip is how effective
Republican disinformation has been. The stuff that
they repeat. January 6th was Antifa. The woman who
was shot, Ashli Babbitt, was a hero. All of these
things that you and I go, there's no evidence
for this. Who could possibly believe this crap?
Here are the people who believe this crap. And the
most important message I have for you about it is
the MSNBC didn't go and have to look in
little crevices to find folks with these
beliefs. This is a disturbingly representative
sample of, I would estimate, somewhere between
one fifth and one third of the voting public.
This is scary dystopian stuff. Look at this
and look at how weaponized their beliefs are.
Speaker 4: Doug Mastriano was at the insurrection
and he was photographed breaching one
of the restricted areas. Is that OC?
Speaker 3: Which area? Because I saw
a video where Capitol officers are
taking away barriers and unlocking doors. Yes.
Speaker 1: So that's the talking point. There was
no trespassing. The officers let everybody in.
Speaker 3: I mean, they opened the gate.
Speaker 4: So it shouldn't be disqualifying
for an elected official January six.
Speaker 3: He didn't strike
anybody. He didn't hurt.
Speaker 5: Anybody.
Speaker 4: And the only one that died was
a protester there, not a Capitol Police unarmed
female veteran. That's the only one who died.
Speaker 2: And the only one who died.
Speaker 4: A police officer.
Speaker 1: Member, unarmed female veteran died.
This is the whole thing where she she was a hero.
She was there protesting peacefully. And Bubba.
Speaker 4: Did die. No, look, that was a
murder trial. That's not that's not on by that.
Speaker 3: That's. He shouldn't
have been a police officer.
Speaker 4: So what do you make?
Speaker 1: Support the police, right?
The guy who died of a heart attack.
He just never had any business being in
law enforcement. We back the blue over.
Speaker 4: Overall of January six. I mean, it was
watching that footage. It was pretty disturbing.
I mean, there were people throwing excrement at
the walls and it was out against the Capitol.
Almost a lot like antifa's action tomorrow.
Speaker 2: Except on a much smaller scale. It
looked the same as the class matter riots.
Speaker 4: That's what I saw.
The similarities around the.
Speaker 3: Country that burns Kenosha.
Speaker 4: But so it's okay just
because just because one side that
you disagree with. I'm saying all TV training.
Speaker 1: For one is Antifa infiltrated. Now,
understand, if you're listening,
this is a group of all white people.
It's relevant only in so far as when we think
about what is the group most susceptible in a
sense to this type of misinformation. It
does seem overwhelmingly to be right wing
white, mostly male, but lately increasingly female
voters. And that is exactly what we have here.
Speaker 2: Pretty other.
Speaker 3: Anybody.
I don't.
Speaker 4: See.
Speaker 5: Anybody, anybody who.
Speaker 3: Cause property destruction that needs
to be dealt with. And you're there making your
voice heard at the Rivals house, no less. Yeah,
that's again, it's a fundamental constitutional
right of an American citizen and people
should not be being held political prisoner.
Speaker 1: So this is the talking point of the
rioters are being held as political prisoners,
which Marjorie Taylor GREENE uses. I mean,
you could spoon feed anything to
these folks and they would buy it.
Speaker 3: Because of it.
Speaker 4: For misdemeanors.
That's East Germany. Nazi tactics.
Speaker 3: Yeah, that's what's scary.
Speaker 4: It was an actual fiery but
mostly peaceful protest. And the other
ones that there were, this was a protest.
It legitimate in your eyes administration I.
Speaker 3: Feel like is using
that as their race dog fire. Oh,
my God. Exactly what they're using it as an.
Speaker 1: Oh, my God. This is really,
really scary stuff. Really scary stuff. Let's
let's skip ahead and. Listen to a little bit more.
Speaker 4: It after people were still there and
stuff. Yeah, but, but it started while he was
still speaking. And they talk about the fact that,
oh, he didn't do anything for this amount of time.
It's like while he was giving his speech and.
Speaker 1: Right. So this is the argument that
Trump couldn't have stopped what was happening
because he was still speaking when it was
happening. That's not true. We all were there
live. The breach happened. Well, well, well. After
Trump was long gone. But the timing just is a lie.
Speaker
3: Lie to know about was to deny his request.
Speaker 4: Actually, we had several thousand
National Guards.
Speaker 1: Now, again, that's also a
lie. Trump has insisted. I requested 10,000 troops
and Nancy Pelosi denied it. There is no evidence
that Nancy Pelosi denied anything. But more
importantly, there is no evidence Trump requested
any such troops. There is simply no evidence Trump
says it, no evidence of it. They believe it's not
just some of the lies. They believe every lie.
Speaker 4: Yeah, well, it actually isn't
in Pelosi's power to destroy Nancy.
She's speaker of the House. She has
no authority over that whatsoever. And frankly,
I think that's a good thing. But. Well, then.
Speaker 3: But even so, isn't she.
Speaker 5: Charge of security? If there was.
Speaker 3: Cooperative risk that she be
offered them, then why didn't she pretty.
Speaker 4: Much.
Speaker 3: Preemptively beef up Capitol
Police? But she does have the authority to do.
Speaker 1: These are very serious brain worms.
And I know what with that pejorative, there is
something really wrong here. There is something
very wrong where every lie they believe. And the
most important question for us is it's very clear
that just putting up good candidates who tell the
truth and who actually care about constituents,
it is not enough. So what has to happen?
What has to happen? I don't know the answer.
And that may be the scariest
part of all of it. We'll have
these clips on our Instagram. Find
us on Instagram at David Pakman show.